wei is ready for the final and has
qualified and one of these two will join
him live on ironian is up by one point
this is a must-win situation for young
christophe duda in game four and here we
go must-win situation and it's the
queen's gambit it's the queen's gambit
accepted black is one pawn up
temporarily
and uh not the most common variation but
they did debate this
uh this line
in a game earlier already today this
last night move by black allowing white
to get the pawn back and
i slightly prefer white's chances why it
has a nice central pawn there
but
is it enough that is the big question
levon's playing so quickly
it's clear i think in the break between
the games duda has gone away he's
studied this or maybe he's had one of
his coaches one of his seconds look at
this and think and and they've told him
just go for this against levon you have
an advantage or at least you get a
playable position in a must-win
situation and this night retreat seems
to be a new move
so uh
definitely and uh now you can see this
is why lavon pauses and he has to work
out the subtleties why is white playing
this move
i mean what is the plan
is it typical that we see these
novelties in this must-win
games that he has something special
prepared for those situations yeah you
normally want to save your best stuff
for the uh biggest moments right the
biggest occasions where there's you know
prizes there's money there's miami on
the line yeah
and uh yeah it looks pretty nice for
white i like this central pawn at some
point it might step forward later
white's four versus three advantage on
the right half it's easier to mobilize
than black's majority on the other flank
for now
simon i guess you like the potential of
uh yeah definitely i mean
this is the only move i
i was a bit fearful of um
i thought if i was black i'd love to
swap the queens off because i think the
long-term attacking potential of those
four pawns you mentioned
is great i mean at some point you know
you can start pushing them all up the
board and an ideal situation to to to
have i think for duda i think he's
picked a very very good opening um uh so
far and um i i mean should have never
exchanged queens there it's still some
problems actually um so i would i would
say this is yeah good novelty i mean uh
a nice position to have so far oh wow i
mean sometimes those those are the best
novelties not kind of groundbreaking
sacrifices here or there it's just a
simple night retreat white knights
defend each other right now and one of
the white knights supports the central
pawn so it's just coordinating the
pieces i guess and i wouldn't be
surprised if as you mentioned he starts
kind of preparing to launch his kingside
pawns forward or at least the white
f-pawn forward not yet because it would
make the white king vulnerable but
over the next few moves the bar is
slightly over to do that side
he has to win this game to take it to
tie breaks any other result means
levonorone goes through to the final and
he's such an experienced player in the
one do you think he gets stressed at all
in this situation
uh he's been there he's uh done it a few
times
and uh i mean he is one of the kings of
knockout chess if we talk about world
chess
uh so he's won two world cups i don't
think anyone else has ever done that uh
two world cups so it's i mean these
massive knockouts 128 players
um all the best players in the world are
there and he's won it twice wow
dude has won it once hasn't he dude has
won it once by by beating magnus in the
final which was incredible a semi-final
right okay and uh yeah i remember once
having a chat with lavonne and i was
asking him this question you know do you
ever feel stressed for the question he
said absolutely not wow
and not you know especially when he gets
added time on the clock you know he
doesn't worry at all he trusts his
instincts
and uh there we have a little porn move
from duda
and once again aronian has to take a
pause and he has to consider whether to
trade queens or perhaps uh to find a
home a safe home for the light squared
bishop
yeah there's some small problems here on
there david i mean like um
i mean this pawn structure is great when
you need to win because you you've
unbalanced the pawn structure i mean the
more symmetrical pawn structure is the
more likely a draw it's going to be and
just the fact that white's got these
well they're ready to roll very soon at
the board it's gonna it's gonna worry
aronian um i mean he might not be
stressed but he's got to deal with that
that move that david's highlighted there
just kicking the knights away and then
you can kick the next knight away with
the other pawn and they can just come
straight up the board so
it's tricky for lev to play i think very
easy for white to play he has one move
in his pocket
because unfortunately you can't push the
pawns just now
but
it is definitely in the air
so you have to prepare it for one move i
think you can get your dark square
bishop out yeah if you push it now i
guess then that uh black i don't know if
you're flicking a check or do you flick
in this rook move to attack the white
queen
um
still slightly tempting to push it now
but yeah maybe at the very least you
could
bring your rook across
and yeah you will jump in with the black
knight potentially maybe you jump this
way even sometimes to sacrifice a piece
but uh yeah ivanka you're advocating
just bring the bishop out
to this square yeah complete development
have that threat that day that simon
highlighted in the air because that is
such a menacing pawn push
and oh
immediately he wants blood
impatient i thought that was impossible
i i thought that uh
you know the child
what happened to the bar well some of
the ideas i think david mentioned about
this peace sacrifice i mean lev might be
forced to sacrifice a piece only needing
a draw and i think this is the key idea
isn't it i mean at some point yeah for
example with the check already if the
king steps forward this could be painful
for um dude the knight could jump
forward now for example with a check
and already we could see a miniature
with some checkmating ideas the king now
trapped on the edge of the board first
levon flicked in a rook move
ivanka you're surprised by something
here yeah because okay for
because i i peaked i accidentally peaked
and i saw that this actually wasn't
possible there was only one move uh
sorry here
dudes move just sidestepping the threat
isn't actually a good move okay the only
move for white to maintain the balance
is actually to play queen takes rook
whoa that's like whoa white's best move
was to give up the queen for the rook
and then win the black knight but i
guess there's some pressure along this
diagonal but
surely this wouldn't be enough to hold
the balance instead he didn't even
consider that duda
he just moved his queen out the way and
why is this not possible that's the big
question it's a check the king moves and
rather than jump into this square yet he
jumped in with this knight
oh my god this is going to be killer
right if white steps forward with this
pawn the black knight jumps in here
and the knights are just going to jump
and conquer this square with a nasty
check
white's pieces are just asleep on the
other side and of course if this knight
is captured again
whoops this is checkmate i think that
that that night jump's coming whatever
isn't it yeah i mean anything you play
and yeah
nice and could we see
is he just self-destructing duder i'm i
was going to say how are we going to see
duder lose this game in less than 20
moves
good it's possible i don't know if we
rarely rarely see that at this level and
but you called it yvenka you said this
move was premature and it's very
tempting when you're in a must-win
situation to play a little bit too
aggressively and he needed to cover
those dark squares because those knights
they're like jumping around like crazy
rabbits aren't they they're just like
going straight for the king the queen's
coming in all the blacks pieces are
fantastic here and um i i i don't really
know what you can do here even to
survive i mean you have to not take the
night when it comes in give up the
exchange i mean this pawn is even
attacked
i mean oh dear
this is just can you do anything here or
are you are you just completely lost can
you go for example
move the bishop to attack that night and
just give up the exchange and just but i
mean playing this when you need to win
is just disgusting though yeah i mean at
the very least here you can win the
exchange as you mentioned simon a check
and white probably has to give up a rook
for it and black has won material
but uh yeah what else
in the current position it's just
disaster for duda i mean how much would
he love to have ivanka's move on the
board now how much would he love to have
his bishop covering all the dark squares
but he can't have access to the square
anymore look at duda he's
he's realized it's all over already
15. yeah he's he's self-destructed you
know he lashed out he's so desperate to
win
that unfortunately
he attacked when he was not ready
yeah
i mean he's got to find a miracle here
and he's got a hope that lev um
self-destructs i mean it's the only
option and
is that using the time correctly very
tempting to do what he did um
you know it looks like an obvious move
but there was a bit of lack of sense of
danger uh on it on his uh on his behalf
there um because the black knight as
david is showing it just has too many
good squares i mean you can take a pawn
it can you can jump in and go for the
kill right near the king with that
lovely queen coming in as well the
threats are the threats are
ginormous here i mean there's
multiple threats in multiple angles
multiple different pieces
jumping
yeah it's just over and this reminds me
as well of a game that levon aronian
once won against fishyanand
just similar where white's king was
tucked in the corner and then there was
this kind of x-ray from one of the
bishops along this diagonal and this is
a common pattern right if this diagonal
is covered and your king's in the corner
you often end up getting checkmated or
at least some
bad stuff will happen do you reckon
erroneously
[Music]
is he starting to think about the bright
lights of miami he looks very happy
he does look at that yeah miami what
what shirt am i gonna wear on the beach
there
got a fair few is it the bermuda one
with the cat or is it there
no you must never never do that never do
that
i love the english expression and i
don't know whether any other country has
it like never count your chickens before
they hatch
yeah it's true no it's the biggest
mistake in chess to relax
because as soon as you do that you uh
yeah you know you lose your
concentration i mean you can don't do
that yeah because that's we've talked
about like in a football game you can
concede a goal but you can still win but
here
if you make one row move you lose the
game yeah yeah especially if you're
playing one of the best players in the
world they will not let you off the hook
yeah absolutely absolutely not and uh
whilst doodle is scrambling for a good
defensive moves or anything just to keep
the game alive
well we are running a selfie competition
and we are asking how are you watching
the tour show us your pictures and
dmitry stanislav says that they're
watching from home
and uh learning a lot
that's uh the best chess summer ever ah
thank you yeah and thank you dmitry for
watching and uh rahul is
rooting for lavon aronian
and says it's a delight to watch the
show so thank you very much rahul and
we also have a modu watching from
his office in nigeria
all over the world and uh there we have
some moves on the board
yep so white did indeed go for maybe the
most obvious move in the position white
has fully expanded in the center but as
we showed that black knight has jumped
in both the black knights now
i mean they're like
octopuses what's the plural of octopus
i think it is octopi yeah
but either way yeah they've just got
their tentacles around i mean
there are some checks in the air for
example blacks attacking now with two
knights and one bishop why not bring the
other bishop into the attack yeah and i
still you can still go wrong when your
position's so good yeah that's the only
problem another natural move here to me
would be to bring the queen in right i
mean you know i want to get the queen in
it looks so tempting uh but this yeah
this is this is this is a you know
really strong move and yeah i mean is
there any way to
duder can sacrifice the exchange and
fight here that that bishop is lining up
against the queen as well yeah oh my
words it gets worse so knight takes
bishop now which looks like you're
getting out of uh the firing line no
black will not recapture a black wolf
flicking a check
and next move the queen drops
that is uh painful
so not just the king under fire the
queen two
so this diagonal you need to keep it
kind of
blocked but yeah again just to show this
is still a checkmate so the knight is
poisoned the king caught in the corner
i mean i i'm struggling to see do we
have to move the knight in this
direction maybe maybe you have to do
this just to hit the bishop and guard
your own knight but then the knight
comes to f2 anyway and you have to give
up the exchange and be attacked in a
hopeless situation give up a rook you
have to hide your king
i mean you couldn't take the black
knight because of this pin
i mean at the very very least black just
drops back and says try getting out of
this one
yeah and look at dude
looks almost ready to resign yeah and
now we have a check
and down on material and with a dead
lost position yeah but sometimes it's
too embarrassing to resign right i mean
like it's too quick you want to you want
to make it to move 30.
um you know you just
it's too painful right to resign um i
think yeah 20 is my golden number
actually i i i would feel very
embarrassed if i lost before move 20 and
i have been lost before move 20 and i
was like please let me find what moves
to get to that magical number he gives
up his queen too
wow
wow desperation
i mean he only has two nights for that
queen wow promise he's still getting
attacked
i mean i shouldn't laugh but you know
you're you're queen down and you're
getting mated it ain't funny you have to
give him credit for going all in in this
game he had to win it yeah he did give
it a shot this would never happen if he
just uh if the scores were level if it
wasn't a crunch game for him but yeah
levon just too good in this one and
yeah it won't be a miniature
we define a miniature as like a quick
flashy win because it's over 20 moves
now okay but
yeah the survival won't last much longer
and another one comes oh it's just blow
after blow off the blow relentless stuff
here
like you're punching your opponent while
he's already on the floor
such a brutal game
[Laughter]
that's simply a double attack against
the two white knights and
i think he can resign actually now on
passant here capturing this pawn as if
it just moved to one square with white's
e pawn doesn't help because black's
queen on the e file will pick up one of
the white knights
you just i'm just gonna resign yeah any
moment
by the way we've been told that octopi
is not the correct one by chess numbers
but octopuses and optic pods
multiples are acceptable but not octopi
okay
no apparently not okay but octopuses is
yeah
that's a safe one we thought we were so
clever though i know octopus yeah trying
to bluff it out there there's always
someone why is it like tempi and it's
only our first language i mean we should
okay and we have some moves i mean
duder saved one of his knights he traded
it off for black's bishop but still a
queen down for just a bishop and knight
not only that but black's rook on the
third rank is gonna go
gathering he's gonna go crazy and just
grab some pawns
oh it steps back slightly surprising he
doesn't need to right he's going i want
full control over the position
the other rook will also line itself up
in the center
control lavon doesn't even look happy he
just
feels a bit bad for duda
but we have an update
octopi makes sense
because a lot of similar words of latin
origin can be pluralized
chess numbers is giving us some good
info in the chess 24 chat wow so um and
they're having a debate about that
so we're going to call them octopi yes
no octopi
yeah i did see a lovely well it was
quite funny to eat where it says uh
they're a bit shocked that none of us
knew whether neil young was alive or
dead
i thought he was alive it was just simon
putting something i thought most of
these rock stars they don't last long
did they i mean like
if you get over 27 you're doing well so
yeah
all right well
the von neuronian he is uh
with uh almost two feet now in miami
ready to play uh in that major but also
in the final tomorrow against wei
young christophe duda he is still
playing is he just trying to reach move
30
yeah he's i think just coming to terms
emotionally with the fact that
he will be leaving this tournament now
and it could have been so different
but uh yeah sometimes interests
especially when you've had a bit of a
bad game a bit of a bad day you don't
want uh to kind of admit that you should
move on you have to move on but uh yeah
yeah unfortunately the black rooks are
just too strong they're coming in dude
yeah gesturing it's like
yeah what else can i do what have i done
yeah the queen's too good i mean there's
too many targets for her too just too
good i mean uh
yeah it's that that's it's a bit
horrible to see you know after such a
great day of chess that you know do to
go down like that because he's
such a fantastic player and he you you
rarely see him lose like this i mean uh
and it is over yeah christophe duda
loses in the 26 move levon aronian is
ready for the final his first final this
season in the military champion